Prince William comforts a victim of the  fatal London fire if you have to better  handle everything you have to show  strength and you know resilience to  everything but there are some times when  it all gets too much the Duke of  Cambridge broke royal protocol on Friday  when he hugged a distressed woman whose  husband reportedly went missing during  the time of the blaze  typically touching royal members is  reserved for handshakes but William made  an exception for the grieving victim at  least 70 people were killed in the  deadly fire and the death toll is  expected to rise Queen Elizabeth and the  34 year old royal took a trip together  to see the survivors and families  affected by the fire which destroyed the  Grenfell Tower in London Prince William  appeared emotional as he walked around  the devastating scene  [Music]